game one is a draw and is that a good
result for you Magnus uh when uh well
Faby will have to win this match um I
think it's all right um I wasn't
thrilled about the way
um yeah I wasn't thrilled about the way
that I that I handled it I I think my
play was a little bit too too soft I was
thinking after all these exchanges that
I might have some uh good Bishop versus
uh sorry good knight versus bad Bishop
scenario point but it's not um I think
it's not remotely
um realistic so um yeah I I I yeah I
think that was a bit of a m misjudgment
like generally white doesn't have much
in general but the way that I played out
just made it really easy for him but um
yeah at least it's nice to have one game
that's not um you know like
yeah yeah all right m is today we have
been talking about your your goals today
because yesterday uh you checked off
your goal of winning a game from minus
10 position um so first of all uh
resourcefulness I guess was like the
topic for you yesterday what is the
topic for you
today well clearly in the first game a
bit of solidity but I'm I'm sure the
match will take off eventually all right
and uh two more goals here have fun I
have to ask you have you checked that
off in the CCT season this season oh
yeah I mean I've definitely had lots of
fun in in different uh tournaments and
um finals as well it's been a little bit
stressful at times but it's uh still had
some fun moments all right so we're
going to get that checked off but the
third one to win a game with one B3 I
know you can't reveal your openings but
do you have an ambition to make that
happen before the CCT 2023 is finished I
haven't won a game with B3 this season
no okay then uh then I might have to try
and funny that we are talking talking
about that because I don't know if you
checked out Wesley Souls game he played
with 1 B3 and I think he just won that
game yeah I mean what's not to what's
not to like like it's not a terrible
move okay okay well uh not to reveal any
of your opening tactics but what is it
about for you rest of today I don't know
really um I mean so far that's a bit of
a tentative start uh but um yeah we'll
see what he what he uh wants in the in
the in the second game all right well go
have some fun Magnus thank you for
stopping we will get that checked off
Magnus Carlson confirms he has had a lot
of fun in the CCT season this season so
back to you guys